[Music]
my name is nnedi okorafor and i am the
writer of the story line of black
panther long live the king
so what do a condom eat in the black
panther comics in film Wakanda is a
fictional East African nation known for
its great wealth and incredible
technology in Wakanda there are five
tribes each of them is distinct with
their own languages ways in history
Wakanda is an amalgamation of several
African cultures so just as the film
pulls from African jewelry arts Texan
fabrics architecture and music cuisines
of Wakanda would follow the same line of
thinking what Conda is landlocked in
East Africa so we would look to those
surrounding countries for inspiration
for their cuisines Wakanda is a very
wealthy nation so Lokhande in food would
be very rich and have the finest
ingredients they'd have organic
everything the animals that they'd eat
would be clean happy animals you know
much of what what condoms need would
come from what kinda what Conda is
colorful is teeming with life it's
teeming with potential Wakanda is a
dream black panther has turned the
world's eye to Africa in a positive way
in the past we haven't seen proper
representation of African cuisine in
mainstream media and this is one of the
reasons why food is so important because
food in a lot of ways is a
representation of a people and when your
cuisine is not given the stage it's not
shown your absent from the narrative one
of the things about Black Panther that
makes it so unique is its portrayal of
Africa as a place of wealth of diversity
of beauty we know what the stereotype is
around the world the starving African
parts of the world don't even think that
Africans eat let alone have
sophisticated cuisine food is often a
representation of culture and people
African food is
so diverse and it's so full of flavors
and colors and magic if you are not
exposed to African food then you're
missing out an important part of life oh
yes
[Music]